foreign
word I hate is undeterminable in all the
reports so I guess that's it yeah hey
hold on stop right there
[Music]
yo yo yo what's up this is John with the
Dr John deloney show
Happy New Year
happy same you hopefully doing new
things how about that I may be doing
some of the same things
whatever's going on your world I'm glad
that you're with us on the world's
greatest mental health podcast ever ever
created ever recorded ever ever
um
I'll leave it at that thanks for joining
us
um Kelly and I were gonna talk about
something and then she said we probably
shouldn't so remember in middle school
when someone came up to you and they
were like I know someone who likes you
and you would be like who and they'd be
like I'm not gonna tell and I just
didn't tell you that's what I'm doing
right now all right let's go to Anna in
Baltimore what's up Anna
hi
how are we doing okay good good
um so I'm calling because uh well first
of all thank you for taking my call of
course thank you hey how's your New Year
going you doing well
it is yeah we got a little bit of
sickness in our house but I think anyone
that with kids can empathize with that
yes we're doing okay they are walking
Petri dishes really seriously yes
um well my question was
um I get I am struggling
um about a month and a half ago my
spouse was dishonest with me about
something
um I'm just kind of having a hard time
of like where do I land like as far as
how do I move forward from it
um because I just really didn't see it
coming and so what were they just asking
about
so
um there you think cannabis products
which I guess is a separate issue in
itself
um like be more specific smoking weed
taking CBD yeah yeah vaping
um and so he has historically had a back
injury and had used it for pain
um but then before the back end we also
used it um a lot in his young adult life
for like partying and stuff like that
and so
um yeah and so part of us like we've
only been married for like three years
um and a part of that was an agreement
that that wasn't going to be a part of
like a lifestyle and that it didn't seem
like a hard thing for him we sacrificed
it entertainment the hard thing it was a
big issue
um and so I saw her under the
understanding that that was kind of
where we were at still because there was
no conversation you were um and you were
I was yeah
like yeah we both yeah I'm sorry you
were under you all both agreed that he
wasn't going to smoke anymore right yeah
yeah so like part part of when we're
faced with
um
like just I I say gross not like blood
and guts but just like blatant
dishonesty
I often I go to the mirror and be like
oh I must not have been super clear like
I blame myself and so I'm trying to
affirm you here you all had the
conversation and this was part of what
y'all agreed on is that is that right
correct yeah yeah exactly because yeah
it's a good question if there's a
misunderstanding or
um no no so here's here's what I think
you're doing I think you are trying to
squeeze and minimize how bad you feel
because if you don't you're forced to
deal with the reality that your husband
looked in the eye to lie to you for a
long time
right and I don't I don't care about the
weed and all that that's I mean that's a
whole other conversation
y'all made an agreement on who y'all
were going to be and the behaviors
actions you're going to take to backfill
your identity
and not only did he not hold up his end
of the agreement but he lied to you
about it right right and can I say one
more thing yeah absolutely you knew
and you didn't want to know like you
knew he was different or you knew he was
a little bit distant and you didn't want
to come clean either and so you are also
pissed at yourself Fair
yeah
that's a fair that's fair okay um so now
we got a big mess
great
what do you do now
that's my question
I'm calling you idiot
um okay so let's let's he's not here and
we can't do anything about his behavior
only he can right his actions so let me
ask you a couple of questions one are
you a person
that is safe to be honest with
I thought so
it's not a like a I'm not trying to
trick you I'm just asking right yeah no
I am I have
I I have worked in an industry that had
um really close interactions with people
with substance abuse okay and so I think
I'm a little more sensitive
um
to it and so I just I just I think I've
seen it really destroy how many families
stop saying there's something wrong with
you
oh okay
there's not you're not extra sensitive
to it what your husband flawed out lied
to your face
yeah yes I have a problem with it
um you have a problem with this
dishonesty oh huge yeah yes you should
you should absolutely you should and you
have a problem with peacekeeping
and to have a successful relationship
occasionally you have to raise a Ruckus
not like an idiot and not like some kind
of alpha but you have to you have
to raise the temperature of the room you
have to turn all the lights on and say
hey what's going on here
you lied to my face
and it's very fair to ask what else are
you not being honest about
so if that's the case yeah and I I feel
totally agree with that so that that was
the part of the conversation
um when he finally wasn't honest with me
um was was there anything else you're
learning about and the answer is no like
do you just trust that I don't know I
think I think the path back to trust is
different for everybody
okay okay so some people
um some people like want to check in you
I wanna I want to you have to kiss me
every night so I can I can smell your
breath
um every night I'm gonna look you now
and say did you smoke today
uh I want to see your text messages and
read That's only I'm gonna feel safe or
we have a shared bank account and I'm
gonna review the the like like
everybody's everybody's path back to
trust is different
okay and what I'm going to tell you is
um a you can get out of control with
that right where you become a possessive
lunatic and
that's hard to get to
you have a you I I believe you oh no I I
know you are entitled to hey here's what
I feel right now I feel you're not being
honest
and something tells me that you're
calling me because you think he's not
being honest about something else
um
yeah I can't read there's one thing yeah
like I guess
um
get like online gambling for sports just
became legal in the state of Maryland
and so he's been really um engaged in
that and so
I
I he's the one who oversees I mean I
have access to everything obviously but
as far as like finances and stuff like
that he's kind of ahead of that um and
so I sometimes get a little now because
of this I'm like uh like are we okay
with that like is it just a recreational
thing like
your body is telling you you're not safe
and part of the reason you're not safe
is because you don't know because you're
not facing reality you're not owning
reality okay how much money do I have in
my account like here's how much was
deposited from your check here's how
much deposited was from my check where
did every one of those dollars go this
month
how much do you owe to a gambling
website a means like you don't know
where it's going so for instance if I
went to Vegas
I would tell my wife hey I'm taking this
much money
to be stupid with
and she would say well you're an idiot
and but it's part of uh it would be an
agreed upon amount that was that we've
already budgeted for that would be right
so that's different than I'm just
sitting in my in the couch while you're
asleep and I am gambled on this game and
I'm trying to pick it back on this game
right I J I just gave a interview with
um
USA Today yesterday on what is just
people are are getting dragged
underwater with this online gambling
it's madness madness madness
um and so something in your gut tells
you something's not right
and for some reason over the course of
your life you've been
taught to shut up inner Anna
so that everybody else can go about
their day peacefully
foreign
okay
so let me say this Secrets destroy
marriage
okay they destroy relationships they
destroy people
that's number one number two
I think it's fair to sit down and be
Point Blank very very clear
with yourself here's what I'm worried
about here's what I know here's what I
think is actually going on write those
things down because those hard
conversations become very emotional they
our bodies take over for us right and
then we start crying and then we or we
see our partner like kind of get a
little bit there we read facial cues and
then we're like no no I mean I mean not
that I know you're not but we start
hedging our bets right mm-hmm
write down what you are actually
concerned about what you're worried
about the things you need to know to
begin to re-establish trust I know how
much money we have I need to know how
where it goes we're going to make a
budget together I want you to hang on
the line I'm going to send you
um Financial Peace University the whole
class okay okay I work here at Ramsey
Solutions Dave Ramsey is my boss and so
the I'm gonna give you the tools to say
here's what we're gonna do as a couple
this is going to be a path back to
reestablishing trust together we're
going to get on the same page we're
gonna get the same values together we're
going to share money we're going to not
you're not gonna do all the money by
yourself we're gonna do it together
every month we're gonna have a plan now
we're gonna re-establish trust here's
what you have to know though
he might tell you to go to hell
okay
yeah okay
you know that right
I would highly doubt it but like I said
as an option for anyone okay good that
makes my heart feel good I I heard in
your voice I thought you were gonna say
that you were worried about that if you
don't think so great no that's awesome
okay so I'm gonna sing you that
and I want you to read out to him your
letter
okay this is what I need like you
violated our trust
like yes we agreed you weren't going to
smoke weed and all that kind of stuff
well that's a whole other conversation
the bigger deal is you messed up and
then you hid it from me
and now I'm wondering what about our
money I'm wondering about your online
gambling I'm wondering about that person
at work that while you're always texting
somebody when you I'm worried about all
kind of things
and you open the door
and so here's our path back together
here's what trust looks like for us and
again this isn't rage this isn't anger
this is you listening to your body
you're not safe and your body's
literally sounding the anxiety alarms
and for those of y'all listening this is
one of those core moments of building a
non-anxious life
I'm gonna own reality and reality is I
don't know how much money we have in our
account I don't know who's spending what
on how or when and not knowing about
something as important as your finances
are we going to have a house payment are
we going to have rent can I trust the
person I'm sharing a bed with
your body's gonna sound the anxiety
alarms you're going to be anxious you're
going to be fried out you're gonna be
nervous or your body's just gonna shut
the whole thing down you're going to
depress
your body's gonna try to take care of
you
when it recognizes Danger
and Anna trust your guts for the first
time
trust your guts I think you're right on
this one
hang on the line here and Jenna's gonna
take care of you get you uh uh signed up
for Financial Peace University and give
you all a path out of this thing
together we'll be right back
hey guys deloney here listen I get
questions about sleep all the time on my
show and man we have so distorted our
perception of sleep either we pretend
we've evolved past it and I'll sleep
when I'm dead or we over complicate it
and think we need a million products and
pills and anything to get sleep and
sleep is important it's crucial to your
mental and physical health but there are
so many simple things you can do like go
to bed and get up at the same time every
day kill the electronics an hour before
bed and make sure you've got a great
mattress this is one product I do
recommend investing in for Quality sleep
and that's why I love dream Cloud their
mattresses are made with Advanced
Technologies to keep you comfortable all
night for a great price and right now
dream cloud is offering 25 off any
mattress plus 599 dollars in accessories
and an additional 50 discount with code
John deloney it's one word so go to
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney to get your new mattress
today
all right we are back let's go to Ray
it's a shame about Ray and Charleston
West Virginia what's up Ray
hey Dr John it is a privilege and honor
to speak with you today how are you sir
all right dude I'm fantastic and it the
privilege and honors a hundred percent
mine dude thank you so much for uh
giving me a buzz so what's up man
ah so thank you so much for those words
and I also want to thank you and your
show for helping me with a lot of things
over the over the time I've had
listening to you guys but one of the
things in particular is helping me to
understand the difference between
wanting to lose weight and get out of
debt and wanting to want to oh great
question lose weight and get out of that
okay so you owe a bunch of money
I do I do it's and it's all student
loans how much
at this at this point in time 170.
what do you do for a living
um so I'm a scientist and I work for the
states I work with uh police and
prosecutors and I help analyze the
evidence for them gotcha excellent so
you were not making
um Private Industry money to pay these
things back in short order
in short order that's about right yes
sir and I I hear your voice you're uh
we're not going to give away locations
and details and so I want to respect
that but also I've worked in both
Private Industry and in government
institutions and there's a vast
difference in
in uh how they pay you so there you go
um and then tell me about your weight
dude
so as of as of today I am I'm at 300
pounds so I would say about a hundred
pounds plus somewhere around in that
range over what I should be quote
unquote okay
um so who gave you the should number by
the way
um the internet and
um Health classes and all that there's a
healthy weight to
um height ratio and Ray
you want to know the difference between
wanting to and wanting to want to is how
much time you spend on the internet I
bet there's a direct correlation
so fair point get off the internet and
and I want you to set up a a doctor's
appointment okay
yes sir with the real human that will
look you in the eyes and take give you a
good blood assessment take care of you
and then say here's where you're at
and if you're a great doctor they'll say
here's where we're at because we're in
this together
okay all right so go to uh
so you've man you've dug yourself a huge
financial hole
um to use Dave Ramsey's language you
have a very small shovel because you're
a government employee
and
um do you love your work
honestly yes I do okay this is exactly
what I wanted to to do when I was
um
at the end of high school and into the
beginning of uh the schooling that I did
I really wanted to work in law
enforcement of some kind the police
routes didn't quite fit so I thought
being a scientist for the state working
with evidence a lot better and I'll tell
you what I do think it hit a lot
of the marks for where I find Value and
purpose and work excellent excellent
okay so when you take me back to your
original question and the Genesis of
that question
sure so
I I feel like now I know what it means
to wants to lose weight and wants to get
out of debt and I've heard so many
debt-free screens now now like I can't
say that I can't do it or I don't
deserve to be debt free or lose weight
anymore I just can't I've heard too many
instances of people who are able to do
it
um but there is something I'm struggling
with and I'm hearing these stories of
all these people in their debt-free
screams to work five extra jobs and can
manage four to six hours a night of
sleep
um maybe actually getting two or four
out of that and with the family in the
mix and
Dr John I'm I'm wondering where all this
energy is coming from man
um so there is a tremendous and there's
there's psychological studies here
there's tremendous
um
a couple different things here you've
heard the studies about learned
helplessness
have you heard that
I haven't there's some there's some
famous studies
um that could never be reproduced
nowadays because of um laboratory ethics
and things but essentially they shocked
um animals I think it was dogs in the
original one they shocked animals
to the point of pain
and they didn't let them they didn't let
them out of their their enclosure if you
will
mm-hmm and so the the dogs became Frozen
and when they would intermittently let
them out
the dogs continued to fight and Claw
their way out when they're when the they
were getting shocked when there was a
perceived No Escape
there came a moment when they just took
the barriers away there was no
intermittent they were free to go
and the dogs just sat there and got
shocked
and they they just said this is the way
this is
and it's a common response in people who
experience trauma it's a common
experience in people who
hate themselves
for whatever reason I'm not good enough
I'm always stupid I'm gonna always be a
whatever I'm the worst thing that ever
happened to me
this is just the way this is
and I've run in circles with people uh
myself included who have struggled with
body dysmorphia and working out and
eating disordered eating and being
overweight that's that's been the vast
majority of my life
and the correlation between I'm fat and
I am not worth being loved
is I think that's an a cloud that hangs
over our culture
does that make sense
that does and it sounds like you've been
reading my dirty laundry well so here's
another psychological
um point that I want to hit home
you are more likely to go through a
thing than you are sustainably than you
are to run from a thing
you are trying to get out of debt you
are trying to lose weight
you are not with a smile on your face
walking to Freedom
and those are two different they're the
same path
but they're two different processes
um my friend Sal DiStefano said two
important things he's with the Mind pump
guys two important things and it was
transformative for me just hanging out
with him and we were in interviewing
each other
um he said you cannot hate your body
into better shape
you run out of gas
you just give up you quit you get
exhausted you can't hate yourself to a
better body and the second thing is the
person who loves the journey will always
go further than the person who's
obsessed with the destination
and I butchered that quote a little bit
but here was the transformative moment
for me I became obsessed with getting a
number on the scale for so long and I
never weighed 300 pounds I've never been
obese okay so hear me say that
everything changed for me when I decided
I'm just a guy who takes care of his
body I'm a good Steward of my body
and that was a part of an identity that
was I'm going to be a great husband and
a great dad
and that meant I've got to have energy
to be around my wife and kids that meant
I've got to have energy to help around
the house and the only way I can do that
is if I exercise because exercise gives
me energy and the only way I can do that
is if I'm taking care if I'm eating okay
because if I just eat garbage all day my
my workouts are necessarily it's right
see how it all Builds on itself
yeah it does it does make sense but it's
when I quit getting obsessed with the
scale
now a scale is an important marker it's
a data point but it's not the end goal
it's just it's just a number on a
journey
see what I'm saying
yeah I do you have to decide Ray
can I just ask you this
um
man who told you that you're no good
[Applause]
Dr John elementary school kids are mean
man yeah they are they're ruthless they
they are ruthless yeah and middle school
kids are much better no they're
sophisticated and ruthless and high
school kids yeah high school kids are
just evil
[Music]
um
yeah
going through school feeling alone
and I didn't really have many I didn't
really have many friends I would even
just say many acquaintances let alone
friends
and I finally got a friend that from
high school after high school you know
what I mean
so he's actually one of my best friends
now ride or die but it was pretty lonely
what about a home in high school
um
mom
I grew up in a divorce household okay
um my mom loves me to death
um she did the best that she could
raising me and Mike me and my siblings
um all on her own
um
but
uh me and my siblings didn't quite like
each other either so
somewhere along the way you could run up
you picked up the message two things
you're not good enough
and you're never going to be good enough
the second you went looking for power
you went looking for power as being a
cop you went looking for power with
Advanced degrees
right I'm going to show you
and
man
you've developed this idea that if
you're not that you have to be punished
for something and I don't know what that
is we could talk about that probably for
a while
but let me tell you man you don't have
to hurt
do you yo-yo a lot
foreign over the years have you lost
weight and gained weight back and lost
weight and gained gained it back
I think you're reading my mail too Dr
John I've I've have been yo-yoing for
the last 10 years
so as soon as you lose a bunch of weight
and you start to feel good there's
something inside of you that says no
we got to be punished
we're no good
and that is the voice you have to that
voice doesn't get a vote anymore man
um because that voice has taken their
dad from their kids
that voice is taken somebody's husband
away from her
and I don't know whose voice that is man
but that's the one
is that fair
no it's very fair that's very fair
if you can believe that you're worth
loving
being loved and I don't mean that in
like the rainbows and gummy bears kind
of way although I dude I love gummy
bears
but I mean like you're like tell me
about it the um you have to decide
I'm worth not hurting
I'm worth
um
a life of joy and laughter and here's
the deal man you're gonna have to
practice that because you've never had
it
[Music]
you thought your doctorate or your
master's degree was going to fix you and
it didn't and you thought that one
friend was going to fix you and it
didn't and you thought the first time
you were going to be with a woman was
going to fix you and it didn't
Fair
very fair because that's inside of you
Ray
do you want that
I do I really do you promise because I
don't believe you you really do
yes sir I really really do like walking
to Freedom
now listen here's what this looks like
I made a bunch of promises to myself
this year
I made a bunch of like commitments I was
really like my wife and I went on our
annual Retreat we go on every year to
talk about who we're gonna be and what
we want to be about and what last year
was about where we're going and
yesterday Ray yesterday
I consumed twice my body weight
in so it started somebody left a thing
of brownies on my desk and I got back
from the holiday break and then there
was this little uh Snowman full of
marshmallow chocolate covered candies
and dude
I went crazy
and here's the difference this year I
felt terrible yesterday I have a hard
writing deadline I got nothing done I
was just a spinning out mess
and here's what I did
for the first time in my life I smiled
and said all right
I got tagged today
and tomorrow it's game on
and this morning I got up and I went
back to the gym
did what I needed to do was with my kids
I didn't go to war with myself I didn't
declare civil war against me I'm not the
worst loser ever dude dude I ate a lot
of candy yesterday and I felt terrible
and then today's a new one that's what
this is going to look like for a while
while you're practicing
not hurting
this crazy idea called hope
so tell let me hear it again are you 100
in
I am 100 in yes sir all right here's I'm
gonna give you
number one I'm gonna give you my friend
Dr Lane Norton's carbon app
it's the best coaching weight loss app
on planet Earth
okay it's the one I use it's the one
professionals use
and it will it's I mean it walks you
through calories and how the whole thing
works and it it like
um keeps track of your protein intake
all those kind of things okay
I'm gonna give it to you for free and he
is it's gonna be a lifetime membership
for free you never have to pay for it
okay but you gotta promise me that
you'll use it cool ah Dr John I'm
speechless hold on we're still I'm not
done I'm not done listen I'm also Gonna
Give You Financial Peace University the
whole class the every dollar app I'm
gonna give you everything
okay
I'm not crying Dr John your crime man
listen I'm gonna give all of it to you
and here's the only thing I'm gonna ask
for you in return two things number one
that you actually use this stuff
number two that you keep me updated on
your progress
is that fair
it's more than fair okay sir thank you
um
you are worth being able to laugh you're
being able to you're worth being able to
roll around on the floor with your kids
you're worth being able to have a
reckless sex life you're worth thinking
I need to take a second and third job
and I'm I I but I'm too exhausted to do
it
can also tell you this you're probably
worth more than 65 000 a year you're
making
you don't believe that but you are
and I have found over the course of my
career I've got a particular set of
skills it's very small my talents are
very like I guess you got one or two or
three of them
but they
are valuable in a number of different
Industries
and it may be that right now you've dug
yourself a huge 170 000 hole
I may need to go look and see if I need
to do something else for a season and I
may shock myself because that I love
that work too maybe not
but maybe
okay
actually still I'm gonna give you my
friend Ken Coleman's get clear
assessment too I'm gonna give you that
one also that way you can go through and
say is there another job out there for
me okay I'm gonna hook you up in the new
year
but we're going to turn this whole
sucker around is that fair
that's more than fair Dr John thank you
all right I want you to hear you say out
loud I'm worth being well
I am worth being well and I do not hate
Rey
and I do not hate Ray
dude
now you're on the path
it's gonna nah it's gonna suck man it's
not gonna be fun
impact's gonna be miserable because
you're not only having to budget your
money and take a second and third job
and say goodbye to your kids
and learn how to eat
um in a way that's healthy for you and
to start exercising not as though you're
gonna lose 30 pounds but because this is
who you are
that's gonna be hard but you're also
gonna have to learn for the first time
to stop hating Ray
you're gonna have to learn how to live a
life full of joy and optimism
and not a joy of misery and pain I gotta
hurt and I gotta hurt and I gotta hurt
you're worth it my brother you're worth
it
Ray let's go make it happen we'll be
right back
all right we're back let's go to Ann in
shot in Cheyenne that sounds awesome hey
what's up Ann and Cheyenne Peter Pan
with a plan what's up Stan
I like your Rhymes I'm I'm a I'm a a
rapper too
okay I'm actually not I'm not even close
not even close what's up well we all
have to have a uh closet personality
I have so many Personalities in the
closet for real you have no idea and you
have
none no no all right so what's up
a lot so uh I wrote down the question
because I knew I couldn't get through it
otherwise let's do it let's do it okay
um my question is how do I make healthy
Memorial to the past in the midst of
grief well not
stuffing it or giving away to the
busyness of now in preparing for the
future
be more specific
um
and and let me say let me say it this
way
of course you can't you've lost somebody
right
yeah okay so listen we're going to be
real Direct in this call okay okay and
you've been masterful at managing this
by speaking above it
but we're gonna link arms and we're
gonna walk right through the middle of
it cool
true okay okay
um let's head in
uh well um
I lost
I lost uh two months ago
um to
well uh the one word I hate is
undeterminable in all the reports so I
guess that's it yeah and
um hey hold on stop right there
yeah
I'm so sorry
thank you
what was what was the baby's name
I didn't hear you oh banaya banaya yes
it's very unusual name spell that
d-e-n-a-i-a-h-i-a-h banaya beautiful
and tell me about this little boy was he
a mess
because of delivery okay with a healthy
pregnancy beforehand and just suddenly
something went wrong with the delivery
so he was in the NICU for
um over a month
and the the lovely emits covid and
all the hospital regulations and that's
a whole other story
and so um
is just
and then we moved and
move States
and so it's
it feels like
I I always say that it feels like I was
still in time from him because he was
only alive for 10 months and
it was it was one thing after the other
the others together so
but um I mean he was making progress and
he was even going to therapy and they
were telling me that the six-month plan
that they had that he might be crawling
and everything and I was so happy and
then the next day I found him cult
that little boy won the lottery when he
got you as his mom
you did
and Mamas are not supposed to hold
babies and you know that right
I know that
I'm so sorry
it's against the rules it's not supposed
to be that way
foreign
so that was two months ago
yeah okay does it feel like the
the lights are still turned down low and
you're still breathing through fog
it's right where you need to be
and anybody who tells you otherwise they
they don't get a vote okay
great gift you can give those kids
could you tell mommy's really sad today
if you don't they're gonna think it's
whatever's going on in the house is
their fault okay
true
and so a great gift you can give them is
to say Mommy's thinking about banaya
today I'm very sad
okay yeah
yeah let them see they will they will
see themselves by the Light of the love
you show for banaya
okay
okay they'll they'll feel the the warmth
and the heat from that you're not taking
something from them you are lighting up
their world with that okay
have you um sat down and written banaya
a letter yet
okay you need to do that at some and
there's no rush on it and I would
recommend that you do that with your
family
that everybody draw a picture
and they write they'll write a letter
and you all get together one night and
you'll do that together
it can be to to honor month three it
could be to honor month six but some
sort of private gestials
here's a letter I wrote to banaya
and feel free to put up a stocking to
keep his picture up right yeah
but all that stuff is for tomorrow right
now it's yeah you're going through the
motions man do you have is um Dad around
um because we just moved he's been
pouring himself into work okay he's also
pouring himself into work because that's
an um an anesthetic
I know I know listen
people lose their marriages over this
because they agree people grieve
differently and it causes a wedge
between them
all right
so do you want the um curveball yet are
you pregnant
yes congratulations
because because why not
hmm
so
what I'm about to say is going to sound
trite and stupid and some idiot's gonna
um
I don't care you can read the comments
yeah exactly your grief is gonna be it
is very very valuable
it's not good I don't wish it on anybody
but it has deep value
and
celebrating the life of your new baby
will also have deep and profound value
okay
and one doesn't replace the other
that's what I've always feared
it it it won't
but I will always be with you
you will get a plus one
not a replacement okay okay
and even if you and your husband decided
we want to have another baby right away
and get pregnant right away
that's okay
realize gotcha gotcha so you're five six
months away all along
here we go right
so you're gonna be nervous and you're
gonna be anxious and you're gonna be
wired up and you're going to be freaked
out and all that's normal and good
okay
yeah
do you have a couple of women that you
can that will ride with you through this
um
here um me and most of them are
uh across the state lines unfortunately
listen I can't I cannot recommend it
enough
have a text thread of women that you
trust
that you can just that call them find
three or four of them and say I'm I'm
specifically picking you
y'all are gonna be my ride or dies
through this pregnancy I'm gonna text
you at midnight and say I'm freaked out
and I want you just to text me something
back hilarious or text me something back
some silly dumb saying that you got off
Pinterest or whatever I don't care
whatever works for you okay and
let them know they're you're going to be
reaching out to them and I want you to
be crazy slash real real Brave
and I want you to go find a class go
find a support group or something in
your new community of women who've just
lost a kid women who have are
um moms who are fill in the blank but I
want you to go find some real human
beings in your local area that you can
point to and that they can you can see
them and they can see you you cannot go
through this next season alone
mm-hmm
do you promise me you will choose to not
do this thing alone
okay this is for you this is for your
kids this is for banaya this is for this
unborn little baby
okay it's for your husband everybody
um what does your husband think about
having a new kid
oh he's over the moon
I'm the one that can't I'm the one
that's
I thought you just can't connect I mean
all the other kids I could connect even
though I was not expecting them I could
connect with them but
you're searching for feelings right now
and your bodies have shut the feeling
switches turned them way down because
rightfully so
right
um
that's when we have to lean on what you
just said and I know this gets a bad rap
but going through the motions but we're
going to do the things that we know keep
us well even we don't feel like it
I'm not going to sit there and and
scroll on social media I'm gonna go for
a walk
I want to have seven large pizzas I'm
just gonna have one have one right and
not really but I I want to
oh I would
no no Ben and Jerry Knights I mean I'm
not gonna take that from you
I may have one or two though so I'm not
gonna take that for you but
um but again 80 20 right on the whole
we're gonna do things that we know even
we don't feel like it
because with with your what's your
what's your oldest kid's name
so you had this Bond instantly like oh
man I'm doing this for you and we're
going we're going on walks and we're
going for you don't have that right now
and so we're gonna make a list of things
and we're gonna have some people in our
life that help keep me accountable who
are going to check on me today have you
eaten today
something with protein in it
right and I know you're going to be in
the store looking at the Ben Jerry's
things on the back to see how much
proteins and hey I get it
oh
[Laughter]
we're gonna do the things that we need
to do
over this next period and
um
I'm gonna tell you something really
really hard okay
wait you haven't yep yeah not yet
okay
and
um
I want you to hold your hands together
right now
and I want you to interlock your fingers
okay
but I don't want you to squeeze the crap
out of your hands I just want you to
hold them Loosely for a second okay
and I want you to hear me really closely
the last awful thing you saw
of banaya
the CPR
the yelling and screaming
that picture
you are not keeping him Alive by going
back to those thoughts all the time
three
okay
those thoughts your body will go back to
them because it's trying to protect you
from that ever happening again in the
future that's what it's trying to do
it's trying to help out
and it's making it much much worse
and so what I want you to do
is I want you to think of two or three
or four of your favorite memories of
banaya
the time when that goofy little boy
smiled at you
or he almost
almost crawled a little bitish and you
cheered and then he kind of got startled
whatever those moments are
or your other kids messing around with
him
can I have videos so many videos
when the lightning bolts strike and the
lightning bolts of
your walk past the hall and you look
over and you see that or you may not see
him in the in his crib but you feel it
your body responds as though he's there
I want you to practice what would be the
hardest moment of discipline of your
entire life
is I want you to stop take a deep breath
exhale hard
and picture in your mind intentionally
one of those hilarious fun silly videos
okay and here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna consciously over time
teach our body that we remember banaya
we're not remembering the terrifying
scary moments
we're remembering the moments with smile
on his face
when the house was full of light
and you're not doing a disservice to him
you're not doing a you're not somehow
whitewashing over what happened none of
that you're honoring his memory
by letting his memory reside in you as
light not as the heaviness of what
actually happened does that make sense
yeah and you're never gonna fully let
him go he's part of you he's your family
okay he always will
you'll get some dope tattoo one day or
something I don't know but don't do that
while you're pregnant that would be
incredible
um needles before sewing and that's
their only function I agree to
disagreement it's cool it's cool
um but
I want you to write him a letter and hey
while you're at it write your new baby a
letter is it a boy or girl have you
found out yet
um girl
I think John uh is a great name just
hashtag we've already
boo I'm just kidding hey write her
letter too
and let her know you are super jazzed to
see her and you can't wait till you get
to tell her about a little brother that
she had because she never got to meet
him but man he was a character
mm-hmm
is that fair
yeah
okay hey
um you're one of the bravest people I'll
talk to
this month
I'm grateful for you for sharing your
story
do what
I don't feel like it I know
your feelings are all all muted out
right now
true but one of my big promises on this
show is I won't lie to you and so I'm
I'm telling you the truth
you're a brave mom who's dealing with
the worst thing that could ever happen
to a mother
and you're getting up every day
and you're making sure your other kids
are fed
the other kids are warm
and you're making sure that you're okay
because you're now carrying
a new baby
[Music]
and getting up when we don't want to
heading into the fire every morning
[Music]
that's bravery
that's you
so grateful for you Anne benayo won the
lottery when he got you
and I know you won the lottery when you
got in
[Music]
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show hey
thank you all for hanging out with us um
thank you for man yeah just a slate of
Brave callers today
um
song of the days
shout out to the first caller from Tom
Petty and the Heartbreakers
Mary Jane's Last Dance if you know you
know she grew up in an Indiana Town had
a good looking mama who's never was
around but she grew up tall and she grew
up right with them Indiana boys and them
Indiana Knights I don't even know what
that what does that mean
I don't know what Indiana night is well
she moved down here at the age of 18 she
blew the boys away it was more than
they'd seen I was introduced and we both
started grooving she said I dig you baby
but I gotta keep on moving on keep on
moving on
Last Dance With Mary Jane one more time
to kill the pain I feel some are
creeping in and I'm tired of this town
again
now you know why that's Kelly's favorite
song hey we'll see you soon
[Music]